really nice right here tom
number one just went off she wants to go
something doesn't she
this could get exciting
a faction
I'm Sean Casey a documentary filmmaker
we are currently in Skagway Alaska and
we're about to motor 200 miles to the
middle of the Laskin wilderness to get
the opening shot to my new large format
film extreme weather now you can't plan
for that's the bottom line you can't
plan for how wet it's going to be where
your campsite is going to be what the
situation is going to be you bring
everything you think you're going to
need but there's always going to be
stuff that happens that you can't
control and it's about how you deal
about how you deal with situations like
that how you rebuild and how you forge
on it's all about adaptation when you're
doing this kind of filmmaking and this
isn't filmmaking where you've got you
know food truck we've got support where
you can call for anything you need this
is kind of remote adventure filmmaking
and whatever you bring is what you have
this is how it's always been up here
just raw beautiful but in that rawness
things can happen quickly weather
conditions are constantly changing
there's a multitude of things that can
go wrong
but you have to push through these
things because this project is important
about our weather and how it's changing
becoming more extreme we filmed massive
dust storms and the droughts in the
western United States tornadoes in the
Midwest wildfires of California and the
heroics of firefighters trying to
control them it's all about powerful
images for this format so if we could
get a glacier calving directly at us and
that would be incredible
it's going to go only issue is it's that
area that's going to count there's
another down that's going it's going to
go before we get there it's going there
goes I want to be as close as we can but
there is a very real danger of being hit
it could be car sized chunks of ice
flying hundreds of feet from the glacier
it's thrilling it is nervous
it's one to ten on the glacier so we can
reference or someone see something
happening right now seven right there
chunks of ice are falling off on each
side
could be offensive
oh my god